[Music]
let's run out to the youut Salt Lake
City the SLC and talk to Eric good
morning Eric what's up man hey John
thanks for having me on the show of
course dude thanks for calling what's
happening so I am uh uh been married for
a few years now uh I I had a a a
question regarding disagreements with my
spouse how do I make sure that my
wife feels validated during
disagreements or uh but especially when
I'm pretty sure I'm
right oh awesome it's it's important to
me that she feels like she's been heard
and listen to and I try really hard to
you know and I feel like I'm pretty good
listener and I'm able to articulate her
position and and I try I don't talk down
to her at least I don't think I do but
she seems to leave a lot of these
disagreements in a position where she
feels like she hasn't been heard or or
or she feels sometimes she even feels
kind of dumb and that's not what I want
for her yes I'm trying to figure out
where where I'm where where am I going
wrong
um you are bringing a grenade launcher
to a game of
Uno and
um you said I I I really like I I want
her to be heard I want her to feel heard
and then I was going to interrupt you
and say but not as bad as I want to make
sure that she knows that here's the
Right facts of what we're discussing and
so that becomes a hard thing to deal
with So you you're calling for a reason
give me give me the context for what
happened for whatever happened most
recently yeah I mean this has happened
more than once of course but it's uh
no man put on the spot there there is
a a a small pattern emerging to where
hold on dude there if she was on the
phone right now she would be like I
can't breathe and you're like there's a
small glitch in The Matrix I love it
dude because you know why you took your
husband husband protractor out and
measured it it's a very small Rift I've
measured it um it's a small it's a small
fracture in our marriage and she's like
it's so wide anyway okay what's the
small Rift
emerging no my uh this is so great it's
it's I I was thinking really hard before
the call trying to think what did we
actually argue about uh uh uh and and as
I'm thinking back most of this
agreements and arguments we have tend to
be uh uh at least from my perspective
you know when she's feeling very
strongly about something or she's
feeling she she can lash out sometimes
towards me when she's feeling emotional
about something give me an example and
uh well we well well just to make it
that much more complicated we have a
four-month old baby okay so counts right
now because your house is side nothing
count but but give give me a thing she's
very passionate
about uh well she she's she's tired a
lot and so she you know she she is when
she is feeling extra tired she tends to
you know she'll raise her voice or
she'll
she'll about what about what give me an
example of a thing well for examp for
example a few nights ago I I got up in
the middle of the night to you know to
go use the restroom and and then let the
dog out and you in the middle of the
night came back and she kind of let
loose on me saying why why are you
making so much noise you're keeping me
awake yeah you're you're you're you're
it's really I can't you know I'm just
I'm already so short in sleep and you
know she just kind of unleashes a a
barrage and I'll attempt to to listen I
don't I don't raise my voice or anything
but it feels like I'm suddenly being
assaulted for a very normal nightly
thing and and I'm tiptoeing the best I
can I'm not sure what I can do better uh
and so I my my response would
be I get where you're coming from why
are you why you know why are you yelling
at me right now why am I being assaulted
uh with you know with with yelling and
and my guess is my guess is you you
immediately default like all of us would
to a measurement of the amount of volume
you just expended I literally just
tiptoed I opened the back door I went to
the bathroom I didn't even flush cuz I
wanted to be quiet which is gnarly but
it's better than waking you up and yet
right and so for you it's a matter of
data it's a matter of
facts and what
you um let me say it like
this first and foremost during the
disagreement it's never a good time at 2
am with an exhausted postpartum
wife who shows up in the daytime and
feels so much shame that she's a
exhausted yet feels so frustrated that
she's exhausted and wants to be a good
mom yet is being told by every voice on
planet Earth that she's not doing it
right she should be more organic or less
organic or be vaccinating or how dare
you vac whatever's going on and she
really misses the old y'all but the
there's a new y'all all that stuff is
playing in and then the fact that she's
got three hours of sleep a night for the
last four months and
so I don't want to equate that to a
toddler okay but um think of it this way
um because a a your wife is not a
toddler but I'm going to use this this
Sim
similarly okay if my toddler was to walk
in let's say my daughter was four and
she came in and said Daddy I'm really
sick I'm really sick I don't feel good
and then she barfed all over me I could
get frustrated that my daughter threw up
on me but if I step back for point one
second I'll realize that my little girl
went to the one place that she knew to
be safe when she didn't feel good and
that was
me and she barfed all over me which is
disgusting I can argue with her in that
moment about the right place to go barf
and next time you need to be that's what
she's coming for me is Dad can you help
me do you love me and so in the middle
of the night with an exhausted
postpartum wife when she rolls over half
out of her mind and says why are you
making so much noise why are you
whatever the correct answer in the
middle of the night is I'm so sorry baby
and then next week when y'all are having
breakfast together and the sun is out
then it's hey I I really don't want to
wake you up in the middle of the night
are there some nights that would be best
if I slept in the guest
room because I want you when you have
those precious hours of sleep let's get
those those hours of sleep in and the
challenge that a lot of is this your
first
kid oh yeah yeah okay I'll challenge a
lot of new especially fathers feel
husbands and fathers is their whole life
gets taken from them and they take it
very personally I did I remember weeping
that my four-month-old five-month-old
six-month-old son couldn't care less
that I existed and his mom the love of
my life my wife I lost her romantically
I lost her in person I'm trying to have
a conversation and she's half asleep
she's having to get up every two hours
to feed this creature that keeps eating
and eating and she's changing 5,000
diapers a day like I felt like I lost
everything and it wasn't until things
slowly came back but I took my son's
response to me personally I took my
wife's response to me personally and
going back to my daughter throwing up on
I I that's not a personal attack if she
was 19 and got drunk and then came into
my room and and stuck her finger down
her throat and barfed in my face then
now we got another problem right but
it's a different it's a whole different
situation and
so I think there's a time to express hey
how do we solve this problem it's almost
never even if she wasn't pregnant and
y'all had two like teenage kids it's
never in the
fight it's always after the fight
because here's the
deal when somebody's feeling something
during a
disagreement they may be feeling
something while you know something
different what does that mean yes you
should have changed the oil that's a
fact and she's
feeling yes I'm stupid that's a fact
fact and you might say I told you to
change the oil that's a fact and she
might be feeling you are an ass that's a
fact right and what y'all are doing is
y'all are both all the things y'all are
thinking and feeling are facts but
you're not talking to each other you're
talking past each other because your
bodies are trying to survive you survive
with facts she survives with feelings
and that's
okay it's just not the moment to say
okay how can we create a world where
you're going to change the oil in the
car see what I'm
saying yes so the feelings are often
disconnected from reality from Facts
from data and that's okay feelings job
is not to tell the truth or to keep you
safe so when your wife rolls over half
asleep half out of her mind because
she's trying to take care of this baby
and she's like I think 9 plus 9 is 48
you can go good night baby I love you
we'll talk in the
morning right sure sure um tell me like
as a new dad H are you feeling that lost
in space kind of taking it personal kind
of this all kind of is awesome but all
kind of sucks you know for the first few
weeks yes but I've I and thanks to your
show I've heard you talk to other dads
and it's actually helped dramatically
I'm I'm in a much better spot now oh
good for you man it took me a long time
to get out of that man that was a
disaster what about me man no man my
wife is a rock star and the baby's
amazing and I'm just making it up as I
go and so I know I'm I'm making mistakes
and and uh but I'm I'm grateful to have
the family I do I can't couldn't be
happier do you have two yeah and but
here's a deal both you can have both at
the same time you can be just like
profoundly universally grateful for your
family you can watch your wife in action
and it's something to behold and you can
watch this little baby slowly start to
make faces and recognize you and snuggle
in I mean all that can be true and you
can miss your old
days and you can miss just making out
whenever yall want it to and you can
miss just going to bed and going to
sleep you can miss all that all that can
be true at the same time do you have a
couple of guys that the first time I
didn't have this and I watched my wife
have it and it saved me the second
time having a couple of guys that you
literally ask hey guys y'all have three
five seven kids down the road for me I
don't really know what's going on I'm
going to text y'all and I'm going to
text yall 247 365 I need some right spot
on wisdom whenever I
text do you have that you know up until
recently I've not had much of a you know
a posy at all uh I've been really
working hard on changing that and
recently I've been developing a few new
friendships but I don't have anything
you know really deep rooted yet okay but
I suspect that if I would ask these guys
they'd probably be cool with that I
think I can think of nothing cooler than
one of my buddies to reach out and say
hey I'm you're going to be on my list of
three that I'm going to text at um 10:00
night when I can't get this baby to
sleep and I think or there's a weird
rash I'm going to text you guys and um
or when I think my wife's crazy I think
my family's crazy and I'm running for
the hills I'm going to text you guys and
probably three out of three of your
close buddies if you texted him in the
middle of the night the other night and
said my wife's all mad that I'm making
too much noise they would be like bro
just go in the guest room and go to
sleep like this is not the moment to
take your stand right um and I think
there's something powerful about sitting
down down in front of your wife and
saying honey I want to be the best
husband I can be and I know you're so
tired I don't ever ever want you to feel
like I'm waking you up in the middle of
the night what if on those rare nights I
slept in the guest room or if I do have
to get up I'm going to go back to bed in
the other room or I'm going to go back
to bed on the couch cuz those hours for
you are precious and few and far between
probably what she's going to say is
you're not waking me up I'm so sorry and
then y'all can navigate what happens
there or she might say good sucker go to
the couch and then hey you've got your
answer right you've got your answer um I
think I think the meta here is this
don't try to
solve disagreements that aren't about
safety if there's one about safety like
we got to get out of this building now
um I don't think so I like okay we're
gonna fight right now because we have to
get out of here because there's a safety
issue but if it's a matter
of you should have changed the oil and
suddenly she's overwashed in in shame
and feels stupid stupid and here comes
her husband telling her the facts again
and the only way she has to defend
herself is to call you stupid and you're
overbearing that's not the moment for
you know every 3,000 miles except for
unless you're using synthetic and you
could be six it's not the moment for
that in the middle of the night with an
exhausted exhausted mother who's Just
Amazing Just trying to hold her sanity
together with duct tape and string and a
few rocks and pine needles she found out
on the
sidewalk yes she's just going to get
upset with you in the the night if you
even breathe wrong and so cool let's
solve that problem when the sun's up
when we're on the same team when we're
both having a cup of coffee and a shared
moment that that beautiful shared moment
that you can have hey I don't want to
wake you up and again the solution is
about you it's not about hey you keep
getting mad at me in the middle of the
night when I wake up n no no no no
because now she's got to fight you
because you just you just threw a first
punch but instead it's I don't want I
don't want to hurt you I don't want to
wake you up in the middle of the night
and also I got to pee like bad so does
the dog and so what if and then come up
with a solution or two and let's see how
that works out um the cool thing is it
sounds like she's amazing the cooler
thing is it sounds like you're a dad
that wants to really be plugged in and
do this thing right and you want to come
up with a new language let's do facts
when the world is calm and let's do
feelings during the
disagreement and always be the first
person unplugg when feelings get too hot
because nobody's learning nobody's
solving anything it's just war and at
2:30 in the morning with an exhausted
mom or an exhausted husband that's never
a good time you're awesome Eric hey I'm
going to send you a copy of building an
un anous life for you and your new
family congratulations on having this
new beautiful baby I wish you guys all
the best holler if I can ever um walk
alongside
you